[Applause]
Thank You Dean Treanor and Justice
Ginsburg thank you so much for being
here with us today and taking the time
to talk very grateful and our first set
of questions is going to cover how
gender equality manifests in your own
life and Dorrie is gonna start the ball
rolling so you and Marty enjoyed a
remarkable partnership really a model of
mutual support and shared responsibility
safe to say your marriage was unusual
even in today's standards and virtually
unheard of in a prior generation so
here's what we all want to know what's
your secret and no secret Dorie it was a
bluff that I met Marty at a time when
the best degree that a girl could have
was not her BA or her JD it was her mr s
money was the most unusual fellow I've
said many times he was the only boy I
ever knew up till that time who cared
that I had a brain and we met under the
best circumstances Marty had a
girlfriend at Smith College and I had a
boyfriend at Columbia Law School this is
interesting and our friends thought it
was a long cold winter in Ithaca
so we were for two years is the best of
friends if ever I wanted to go to the
movies I call Marty or we often went to
the college spot together just to talk
about anything and everything but the
thing about Marty it was that he had
such confidence in himself it was very
comfortable with who he was and he never
regarded me as any kind of a threat on
the contrary money thought that I must
be really special if he wanted to spend
his life with me
so no self-esteem issues he was always
my biggest booster so um did you
negotiate divisions of labor at home or
and around the family hit me no no
negotiations but we just did what needed
to be done and and at different times I
carried the laboring oar at home marty
was determined to become a partner in
his law firm in five years which he did
so during those years I did most of the
childcare and that continued until he
did make partner and then it switched
when the women's movement came alive at
the end of the 60s and marty realized
that what I was doing was very important
so he took on more of the homework than
he had before I wasn't to tell the truth
face out of the kitchen in an earlier
time by
my daughter so did he teach himself to
cook or do no money in the way he tells
it he said two women are responsible for
his skill in the kitchen one was his
mother and the other was his wife and he
gave his mother a bum rap she really was
quite good and he was altogether right
about me but our arrangement was that
Marty would do the weekend cooking and
the company cooking he never let me cook
for gas then when Jane was starting high
school she noticed the enormous
difference between daddy's cooking and
mommy's really and she sided that I
should be phased out of the kitchen and
for me it was like Tom Sawyer and the
fence brilliant so it sounds like you
were able to make compromises so each of
you could advance your own professional
goals and sometimes he would take a back
seat on his career and sometimes you
would do that yes and sometimes they
made the decision for us I had had an
operation just before I started law
school so then we switched who was doing
the heavier work at home Marty wood was
this is the cleaning and home care money
had an idea about child rearing I don't
know where he read it but he had the
notion that a child's personality is
formed during her first year of life so
he wanted to spend as much time caring
for Jane as he could do you think that
was right I think it would do I think
his theory about the yes in part thought
so can you talk a little bit about
Marty's own family background was
his parents marriage a more traditional
gender role arrangement or were they
also more equal in terms of sharing
responsibilities they were traditional
in the sense that Marty's father had a
good job he was a vice president of
Montgomery Ward and his mother I
wouldn't call her a homebody because she
was a great athlete and a wonderful
golfer so she spent most of her time on
the golf course so were they are
supportive of your goals and and your
choices now if you think marty was
extraordinary
his parents were more more so I've told
many times the advice that I got from my
mother-in-law the day I was married in
the home where Marty grew up and mother
took me aside and said dear I like to
tell you the secret of a happy marriage
oh she knew I'd love to hear it so it
was sometimes sometimes it helps to be a
little deaf that was excellent advice
for the two law faculty is on which I
serve DC Circuit and even today
[Laughter]
but father was remarkable marty was
called into service after his first year
of law school the year I graduated from
college and I became pregnant that first
year we spent in Fort Sill Oklahoma I
was really worried about how could I
manage Harvard Law School with an infant
and if father's advice was or if you if
you don't want to go to law school no
one will think less of you but if you
really want to go to law school you will
pick yourself up you will stop feeling
sorry for yourself you will find a way
and that advice do I really want this
enough and if I do I will find a way
well speaking about support a supportive
boss is very important for women who
need who recognizes that parenthood
requires flexibility and that for women
to achieve their goals professionally
they need a boss who understands that
and we were both moms when we clerked
for you and we can attest that you walk
the walk for sure and they're very
grateful for the flexibility that you
gave us that allowed us to do our jobs
but also be moms so my question is what
was it like for you in the workforce
balancing work and family and and what
were the challenges that you faced when
you first started working after law
school well first let me ask you okay
now how old were your boys when you grow
for me well Nikko turned ten twelve
years ago he was 10 years old this
when I started my clerkship and Benji
was two years younger so 8 years old 8
and 10 and Dori you're you were pregnant
during your question well Louisa was 2
or no by the time I clerked Louisa was 3
and then I got pregnant with is about
during and Isabel that was a tough time
yeah I'm not a happy pregnancy or you
were first a staff attorney the DC
Circuit and I was getting these memos
they were just outstanding head and
shoulders above the rest and so who is
this who is this woman and I'd like her
to be my law clerk so you came the next
year and there was a point in your
pregnancy when you were just confined to
you had to be flat on your back foot I
don't know it was many weeks it was
about four weeks I was first
hospitalized and then when I moved home
I was up in the attic because I had to
be as far as possible from any smell of
food because I just couldn't keep
anything down but you were great you
called while I was home you would call
periodically and catch me up on what was
happening in chambers and luckily I was
able to come back when we started
sitting again in January after the
holidays and you treated me just like
the guy law clerks and yoko clerk so
pretty good yes they were lovely we were
all rooting for you we knew how hard it
was what you look going through I should
say the first law clerk I had who had
childcare responsibilities was not a
woman it was David Post David had gone
to Georgetown at night and his clerkship
application said well going to school at
night because my wife is an economist
was either the World Bank or the
integration
Monetary Fund American Development Bank
yeah and so I have I take care of the
kids during the day take them to the
soccer practice and then so that was
David post I will admit that there was
one other aspect to his application that
made him irresistible most most law
clerk applicants give us that writing
sample their mood court brief for their
law review don't
David Post gave me a paper it was his
first year in his first year of writing
a seminar they were to write an essay
and his was on the law of contract as
played out in Wagner's Ring cycle did
you even bother reading it or was it
[Laughter]
when I remember that first year we
didn't have the internet yet there was
lexis and Westlaw and i went to the
chief and said i have a law clerk who
needs a flexible scared
you
the next year after that every clerk had
access at home
Alexis and Westlaw so my only experience
well when my daughter was born long long
ago in 1955 I was one of very few
working moms in the class and Jane
thinks she was the beneficiary of that
because she kept getting invited for
sleepovers and weekends
skiing weekends she said that the
parents of the her classmates felt sorry
for her because AJ's idea so that she
saw me the better anyway ten years later
this is an example of what changed in
society and my son is born and he's
going to school and it's not at all
unusual to have two other families by
then but still as though the woman was
expected to take care of the children's
inoculations then you choose their
medical check-ups and my son who today
is a very fine human what I call a
lively child and what the school called
hyperactive and I would get calls at
least once a month please come down to
see me meet with the room teacher or the
school psychologist or the headmaster we
would need to tell you about your son's
latest escapade so one day when I was
really weary I'd stayed up all night
writing a brief I said this child has
two parents
please Alden aid calls
and this time this time it's his
father's turn so they did call Marty at
his law firm he came into the school and
he was told and Jameis his latest
infraction and what was it your child
stole the elevator well it was one of
those handheld elevators in it and a
classmate of my son's had dared him to
take the kindergarten class from the
ground floor kids up in fifth grade yeah
that's impressive there's a Marty's
response to these terrible things my son
had done he's also he stole the elevator
how far could you take it I don't know
whether it was Marty's wonderful sense
of humor or their reluctance to take a
man away from his work but after the
elevator incident the calls came barely
once a semester
they were much more reluctant to take a
man away from his work than a woman so
following up on that besides presenting
a united front to schools pediatricians
the like do you have any advice for
working families today with two earners
that are struggling to balance the
demands of a career and the family
responsibilities and for me the two
parts of my life each was a respite from
the other mastani when I was in law
school we had a nanny who came in aid
and left at 4:00 so I was in my time at
Law School I wasn't wasting a minute I
was reading studying outlining all the
time but when it came close to four
o'clock that was it close the books went
home
played with Jane went to the walk with
her and then when she after she was fed
and went to sleep I went back to the
books but having that contrast it was by
the time she would she went to sleep I
had enough of child to go go back to the
books also realizing that you know so
many men wake up one day and the child
has grown and they've had very little to
do with raising that child and they
regret it the the years that you will
spend after your child has left the nest
much longer and if you've lost out on
the opportunity to be part of the child
raising to form a bond with your child
you're really missing something
important in life very true
and I had a similar I used to leave here
at 4:00
my kids were 2 and 4 when I started and
I would pick up a snack in the vending
machine in the cafeteria and run to get
them at daycare and yeah while I was
here I was here and while I was with
them I was with them so my next question
is about moving from domestic to foreign
travels we know you went back to Sweden
this year earlier this year retracing
your steps and we know that when you
were there the first time you learned an
awful lot about Civil Procedure Swedish
Civil Procedure producing a master work
on the subject but we're not going to
ask you about that today what we'd like
to know is what did you learn about
gender equality in your visits to Sweden
and in particular if anything the role
of the courts there first let me correct
one thing he said it wasn't the master
work no it's true it was the very best
book ever written in English on Swedish
Civil Procedure and it was also the very
worst the only so you want to know what
surprised me about Swedish society Odin
what did what were your takeaways in
terms of gender equality there compared
to your experience in the United States
and and you know what were the
differences this goes back to 62 and 63
women were perhaps 5% of the law
students in the country in our country
they were 20% and in Sweden Sweden as
most civil law countries had a career
judiciary so soon after law school you
decide do you want to be an advocate and
a new trained to be a practicing lawyer
do you want to be a judge you take an
exam if you do well enough you go
through
an apprenticeship it's similar to
clerkship and then you go up the ladder
in this judicial career so at that time
there were many women judges and
prosecutors there were very few women in
the practicing bar but I watched one
proceeding it was a it was a trial court
in Stockholm and the presiding judge is
8 months pregnant this is at a time in
the United States when if you were a
teacher and you began to
you
I'm buying from Arizona had taken to
letter mine and she wanted to have an
abortion but she could not get in her
home state so she came to Sweden and
that was a big story in the press then
there was a woman who was writing a
column her name was Abel Moo Baron and
the column was to this effect why should
the woman have two jobs and the man only
one and what she meant was it was
accepted it was thought right and proper
for there to be two incomes in the
family but the woman woman was expected
to do have dinner on the table at 7
takes the children for their medical
check-ups and the rest
there were many conversations some women
and I call the Queen b-type said I don't
need him to share anything I could do it
all you know I'm a doctor and I have a
flourishing practice but his slippers
are acting at his arm trim when he comes
home and there were others who said he
should do a lot more than take out the
garbage so that was revealing that was a
I didn't do anything with it immediately
because there was nothing to be done in
the United States but we're sort of on a
back burner and then when the women's
movement came alive and in the late 60s
I was just
exhilarated with the opportunity that
finding the time was right to make a
change that should have happened long
before well that sort of segues into
another question which is the road not
taken' because you've said before that
if you had actually been hired by
lawfirm right out of school you probably
have spent in career you know as a law
firm lawyer and I wonder whether you
would have actually found that very
satisfying or just being a commercial
litigator or whether you actually sort
of locked out that you didn't get a job
at a law firm and I certainly love dad
and justice O'Connor would tell the same
story if she was at the top of her class
at Stanford Law School no one would hire
her as a lawyer so what did she do she
went to a County attorney and she said
I'll work without pay for four months
and then if you think I'm worth it you
can put me on the payroll how I got my
first job was as I had a professor at
Columbia Law School who was in charge of
clerkships becoming students and he was
determined to get me a job he called
every district judge in the Southern
District of New York
every judge of the Second Circuit and
most of them said he was a free we're
ready to consider a woman she's a mother
and that's just too much but this great
professor Jerry Gunther picked a
district judge who was a Columbia
undergraduate and law school graduate
always took his clerks from Columbia Law
School so Jerry had a carrot he said
give her a chance and if she doesn't
work out there's a young man highly
qualified who's going to in downtown
firm and he'll come in and take over so
that was the carrot there was a stick
the stick was if you don't give her a
chance
I will never recommend another Columbia
students who you
so that's how I I never knew this until
years later when when Jerry told me
about it I assumed because the judge had
do two daughters that he was thinking
about what the world would be like for
them so you gave him the benefit of the
doubt even if you didn't deserve it but
then after that's what it was like for
women of my vintage getting that first
job was powerfully hard but if you got
the job you did it usually at least as
well as the men
so the second job was not the same
hurdle so when I finished my clerkship I
could have gone to any number of law
firms the story that justice O'Connor
tells about her experience she said this
to me well think think of what our lives
would have been if there had been no
discrimination what would we be we'd be
today
retired partners from some launch lover
but because we didn't have that route to
travel we had to find another way so I
think we want to transition to some less
personal questions and more legal
questions
oh all right and she doesn't want to ask
it
it's a silly question but we know that
you studied with vladimir nabokov in
Cornell and we know how much he loved
words and did you ever consider writing
fiction never because I don't have the
talent to do that but Nabokov was a
major influence on the way I read and
the way I write he was a magnificent
teacher very lucky well whatever the
roads not taken one thing is very lucky
for all of us that you took the road you
did so thank you
Alvie rule we will move to a few
questions about the law moving away from
your life and orey's gonna lead us off
again so this year we're celebrating the
centennial of the 19th amendment which
enabled women to vote and in the last
election cycle we elected 117 women to
Congress which is a new record but so
we're making progress which is great but
women have not come close to political
parity in this country we hold just a
quarter of the seats in the house and in
the Senate and of course only 1/3 of the
Supreme Court and we have yet to elect a
woman as president so over the last 50
years the federal courts have been
instrumental in accelerating our
progress thanks in no small part to your
efforts but looking ahead to the next 50
years what do you see is the work
remaining to be done it met and go back
to what you said about impressive
numbers but not enough that's right
there is a very important first on the
Supreme Court this term and it's thanks
to our new justice this is Kavanagh
whose entire staff and all women all of
his law clerks are women and with his
four women as law clerks it's the first
time in the history of the United States
that there have been more women working
at the court and men
so what do I see well personally I
should say what we were doing in the 70s
we were getting rid of all the overt the
explicit gender-based classifications
there was nothing subtle about it it was
women can't do this and they can't do
that almost all of those explicit
barriers are gone what remains is what's
often been called unconscious bias and a
vivid example of that my best example is
the Symphony Orchestra when I was
growing up you know
you
Tom in a famous critic music critic for
the New York Times swore that he could
tell the difference between a woman
playing the piano and a man a woman
playing the violin and a man somebody
had the bright idea let's put him to the
test let's line fold him and see how he
does well he was all mixed up he was
certain that it was a woman whether it
was a man and the other way around so he
admitted that brought home to him then
he saw a woman he had certain
expectations for her and he rated her
that way after that experiment they came
up with the bright idea let's drop a
curtain between the people who are
auditioning and the people who are
conducting the audition so they won't
know if it's a woman or a man with that
simple change there was an almost
overnight shift in people who were
showing up in Symphony Symphony
Orchestra's so I was telling this story
at a music festival some years ago and a
young violinist came up to me and said
you left out something what did I leave
out you left out that we audition
Shoeless so they won't hear a woman's
heels coming on the stage sadly we can't
duplicate to drop curtain in electoral
politics but one of my best examples of
the way of unconscious bias operated was
a lawsuit it was about 1978-79 against
AT&T afford not promoting women to
middle management jobs the women did
about as well as the men up to the very
last test which was called the total
person test
and that was an interviewer sitting down
and having a conversation with the
candidate for promotion it was at that
point that women dropped out
disproportionately and why was that
because the interviewer had a comfort
level facing someone who looked just
like the interviewer but if the person
being interviewed was of a different
race a different gender there was a
discomfort experienced by the interview
he didn't quite know what makes this
person check again so he's feeling
uncomfortable and it ends up in a lower
rating for the woman not consciously to
discriminate it's that that's hard to
get through there was a case before the
European Court of Justice the European
Court of Justice is the highest court
for the for the European Union and it
was a province in Germany that said for
civil service jobs and fields that have
been mainly occupied by men if two
candidates are about equal in
qualification prefer the woman and it
was an argument that was reverse
discrimination
not compatible with the Equality normal
normal the Rome treaty but if you read
the decision carefully you can see
between the lines the court is
understanding that this is not
necessarily a preference for a woman
giving her a plus is a way of overcoming
the unconscious virus that would operate
in favor of the man so that I would save
for women employed today outside the
home unconscious by
is there and the what you talked about
before the the work-life balance but I'd
be interested to know whether you think
the federal courts would play as central
a role going forward because what you
just described that was accepted by the
European Court would not be accepted but
the courts here but there is a statute
that is premise on on the working woman
and that's the family medical and Leave
Act which the court
thank goodness upheld in an opinion
excellent opinion by the old chief and
brilliantly argued by now judge pillared
this past herb litigants in a number of
cases urged the court to revisit prior
holdings in a variety of contexts with
make success and in your view I'd like
to know do you think public perception
of the courts logic in adhering to
precedent whether the court should
consider its place in the system yes I
think all of us do it and no matter
where we are on the political spectrum
the one thing that each of us feels
deeply is we want to leave that
institution in as good a shape as we we
found it we we do not want to do
anything to tarnish tarnish the courts
reputation because it is a unique in the
world until after World War two most
countries didn't have anything like
judicial review for constitutionality
Parliament spoke the last word or what
about what the law was it wasn't until
after World War two that constitutional
courts emerged
in Europe and other places the the HAR
that existed in Germany have persuaded
many people to think that popularly
elected legislators can't always be
trusted to keep the society in tune with
basic fundamental human human rights so
maybe having a Constitutional Court
would be one check against return to an
autocratic government so then we saw a
self constitutional of course growing
the idea of having a court but that
authority became popular but for many
many decades the United States was just
about alone in the world in having a
constitution that was not just
aspirational but law on the ground
law to be observed here and now longer
trumped any lesser lesson law so one
last question before fabulous panel
takes the stage and it's about cases and
we know you've said in the past that you
want tell us what is your favorite
decision that you've authored yourself
because that's like picking a favorite
child yes even even harder but what
about a favorite decision written by
another justice and in specific a
favorite decision or two about the 14th
amendment and gender because that's what
we're going to be talking about with the
battle this gives me an opportunity to
say something about the 14th amendment
because most of the litigation which I
was involved was against the federal
government and where is an equal
protection clause in our Constitution
operating against the federal
government the Fourteenth Amendment says
nor shall any state denied to any person
equal protection of the laws it wasn't
in the fifth amendment for good reason
because when the Constitution was new
the Constitution acknowledged and
permitted slavery so this question of
does the Congress has to abide by an
equal protection norm came came to a
head in the series of cases that were
combined to make brown against Board and
one of them involved DC Public Schools
well DC is controlled by the federal
government so it wasn't a state it was
no Fourth Amendment for teenth amendment
so that's when there was kind of a
reverse incorporation and the court said
that the Fifth Amendment Due Process
Clause essentially incorporates the
explicit equal protection guarantee
that's in the Fourteenth Amendment I
mean they had to do it could you imagine
a Supreme Court saying states can no
longer have law enforce segregation in
schools but District of Columbia you can
it would be unthinkable so anyway what
was the question your favorite decision
about gender equality written by
somebody other
and yourself when you mentioned in a
while I guess Hibbs the Family Medical
Leave Act case but there was a case at
the end of justice o'connor's very first
term on the court
it was Mississippi University for women
against Hogan Hogan was a man who wanted
to go to nursing school and the best
nursing school in the area was the
Mississippi University for women but
they wouldn't accept him
justice O'Connor wrote an opinion for
the court saying you cannot deny to
either men or two women an educational
opportunity simply because of they are
female or male so that case was in C
1982 then in 1996 the court was
confronted with the Virginia Military
Institute case and this time it was
women wanting access to an educational
facility up till then reserved to men
the principle precedent for the Virginia
Military Institute case was justice
O'Connor's opinion and that's another
case where you could read between the
lines so justice Powell who was on the
other side saw the Mississippi
University for women as a kind of
affirmative action for women something
reserved just for them but San Ravi had
experience in life knew it the best way
to upgrade pay in a field that was
dominantly for women is to get men to to
do that that job so she didn't see
Mississippi University for women
excluding men from the nursing program
as any kind of affirmative action quite
the contrary
and that was that Mississippi in fact
well I I brought it home and showed it
to Marty and he read just Oaks honest
opinion he said Ruth did you write this
[Laughter]
any thoughts to share our least favorite
TV series of cases where the court sided
quite wrong it was a question of
acquiring citizenship through a parent
and the law is there I said almost all
the explicit gender-based
classifications were gone but in the
immigration area Immigration and
Naturalization there were this
distinction remain the parents are not
married child born abroad if the mother
is a US citizen the child automatically
acquire as the mother citizenship but if
the mother is the alien and the father
is the citizen a child does not marry
yes so that was just one more example of
the was this a favor to women though
saying that if the child is born out of
wedlock
he's fancy-free he has nothing to do
with the child no responsibility for it
but she saddled with it she can't get
rid of it it's her bird so I didn't see
this and some of my colleagues did as a
something operating but not only in
women's women's favor then he said there
was another one whether it you know
doing this thing the same why but it
would be hard for people of a certain
age
think of a colleague our Revere John
Paul Stevens he had been in the Navy in
World War two and there were a lot of
Madame Butterfly stories that time and I
guess he didn't conceive of his buddies
well I know how many children they sired
as being as yes as having any kind of
bond and being financially responsible
for them so it's hard to break through
that particular mindset so I was most I
agreed with justice Stevens in most
cases but in these cases we have a very
strong disagreement well thank you so
much justice this has been such a lovely
conversation and really a treat and we
all really appreciate your coming here
especially just a handful of days after
the end of a term I cannot believe how
fantastic you look give him that you've
just been through the end of another
time
[Applause]
[Music]
so now Ruthann will escort you off this
stage thank you and so and I will call
the panel up to do the second part about
[Applause]